dans le dernier recensement de
l'agriculture on apprenait que le Canada
avait perdu 3% de son territoire
agricole depuis 2016 et c'est en Ontario
que le problème est le plus criant
ironiquement c'est dans cette province
qu'on trouve parmi les terres les plus
fertiles au pays avec un climat très
doux et a bien des endroits la pression
du développement est-elle que les
agriculteurs ne font pas le poids
[Musique]
j'ai grandi en travaillant pour mon père
et c'était fantastique
j'ai toujours su que l'agriculture était
faite pour moi et que ça me rendrait
heureux
à peine âgé de 30 ans Dean noir suit les
traces de son père il gère avec lui la
ferme familiale à King City tout juste
au nord de Toronto
[Musique]
est très diversifiée on fait pousser du
soya et des haricots rouges et noirs en
régie biologique qui sont vendus
localement
[Musique]
nous fabriquons aussi du sirop d'érable
on produit environ 1200 litres de sirop
d'érable chaque année ce qui est risible
j'en suis sûr pour certains mais c'est
probablement la plus grosse production
de la région de Toronto un secret bien
gardé
[Musique]
mais ce qui n'est pas un secret c'est
que les terres sur lesquelles des son
père cultive incluant les rablières ne
leur appartiennent pas ils en sont
locataires
mes parents n'ont jamais pu s'offrir une
ferme par ici mais on a la chance de
pouvoir louer environ 800 hectares ce
qui suffisant pour pouvoir me payer un
salaire et avoir un employé à temps
plein
je ne pourrais jamais me payer une ferme
dans le coin c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]
l'Ontario est en véritable ébullition
selon les projections démographiques
d'ici 30 ans la population de la
province pourrait dépasser les 20
millions d'habitants et la moitié de
tous ces gens se retrouvera dans la
grande région de Toronto
avec une telle prévision de croissance
le développement se déroule à vitesse
grand
vide
autour de vous ça semble sans fin
construction résidentielle
édifice route industrie tout cela dans
un contexte spéculatif intense la
demande ne cesse de croître
la planification et l'aménagement du
territoire sont relativement
dérèglementées ce qui laisse carte
blanche au promoteur immobilier il
développe selon leur priorité selon les
seules demandes du marché
[Musique]
on construit en hauteur et on s'étale
c'est soit un développement hyper
intensif avec des tours à condos haute
voire très haute soit un étalement à
faible densité en périphérie urbaine
toute cette pression immobilière a un
effet évident sur le territoire agricole
90 ou 95% des terres que nous louons
appartiennent à des promoteurs ou à des
spéculateurs ça veut dire qu'à tout
moment ils peuvent les récupérer pour y
faire du développement
en 1988 quand les parents de Dean horror
ont commencé leur projet agricoles une
terre de 800 hectares dans cette région
de l'Ontario coûtait en moyenne 3
millions de dollars aujourd'hui en
raison de la spéculation immobilière
c'est même terre sont tous fois plus
cher
[Musique]
juste à côté d'une ville des terres qui
ne valent rien parce qu'elles ont une
vocation agricole un agriculteur
pourrait les acheter et jamais ce ne
serait rentable car elles ont de valeur
que si on y construit des maisons
[Musique]
un peu plus loin tout juste au nord de
Brampton
connaît la chanson en quelques décennies
il a vu l'urbanisation frapper aux
portes de sa terre familiale
bref
est arrivé des États-Unis en 1818 et les
premières terres ont été défrichées en
1823 mon arrière-grand-père a acheté
cette ferme ici en 1861 et depuis ce
temps-là elle est dans la famille
[Musique]
au début des années 80 nous avions au
moins trois quatre fermes voisines ici
de la production laitière du bétail
c'était entièrement agricole
[Musique]
la pression urbaine grandissante a
finalement eu raison de ses activités
comme tous les autres tomesen a vendu
setter à un promoteur immobilier
nous avons quitté la ferme il y a trois
ans de voir jour après jour tout se
développements urbain devenait
insupportable nous savions que ça
s'envenait mais c'est arrivé beaucoup
plus vite que prévu il y a eu un immense
développement au sud sur lequel nous
n'avions aucun contrôle
depuis des décennies l'Ontario perd en
moyenne 90 hectares de terres agricoles
par jour et depuis peu cette perte de
territoire s'accélère selon les données
du dernier recensement la province a
perdu près de 5% de ces terres agricoles
productives entre 2016 et 2021 soit
l'équivalent de 130 hectares de terre
par jour
[Musique]
nous étendons nos villes sur la plus
grande concentration de terre fertile du
pays et même du continent une somme
point nous devons nous questionner sur
les limites du développement
de maintenir un tel rythme de croissance
indéfiniment
avant 2009 la ferme derrière moi était
une ferme qui produisait de la
nourriture depuis plus de 100 ans
à 2h au nord de Toronto Bernard Poe veut
nous montrer un exemple de ce qu'il
considère comme du gaspillage de
territoire agricoles un immense parc
d'énergie solaire de 160 hectares apparu
pour répondre à la demande sans cesse
grandissante en énergie
solaire est une excellente idée mais si
on utilise des terres agricoles pour ça
alors ça réduit notre capacité de
production
je pense qu'il y a suffisamment de toi
en ville et ailleurs en région qui
peuvent accueillir ces panneaux servant
à produire de l'électricité
si on perd 130 hectares de terres
agricoles par jour en Ontario on perd
notre capacité à se nourrir voilà un
exemple cette ferme a disparu et la
terre est à jamais perdue pour
l'agriculture
depuis quelques temps le gouvernement de
l'Ontario demande au municipalités de
prévoir leur développement urbain pour
les 30 prochaines années en tenant
compte des prévisions démographiques
déjà plusieurs villes optent pour
continuer l'étalement urbain car pour
les élus la demande est là
beaucoup de gens rêvent d'avoir une cour
pour y organiser des barbecues en
famille il veut une maison unif
familiale d'une certaine manière nous
devrions nous éloigner de ce type de
construction mais la demande reste forte
pour Tom dolsen les pressions urbaines
sont trop intenses pour maintenir en
place des activités agricoles
selon lui c'est presque un exploit de
vouloir continuer à cultiver ici
[Musique]
il est 30 ans trop tard pour sauver
l'agriculture d'ici tout a été acheté
par des promoteurs et ceux qui ont
décidé de rester auront du mal à
subvenir à leurs besoins et à l'église
qui reste à la génération suivante
estime quant à lui qu'il est urgent de
revoir la gestion et la protection du
territoire agricole en Ontario
[Musique]
c'est frustrant de ne pas avoir de
véritables plans de protection des
terres agricoles ni aucun plan pour
inciter les jeunes agriculteurs à rester
dans la région il faudrait s'assurer que
les gens qui ont grandi ici puissent y
vivre encore longtemps
[Musique]
l'Ontario protège certes une partie de
son territoire agricole mais même ses
remparts-là sont menacés par l’appétit
des promoteurs et la volonté changeante
des politiciens
depuis 5 ans nous perdons 1% des terres
agricoles par année c'est incroyable
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une surprise nous savions
depuis 25 ou 30 ans que cela allait
arriver
voilà
quand j'étais jeune je faisais du vélo à
brandten il n'y avait rien ici puis nous
avons assisté à cette croissance cet
étalement
urbain irresponsable
ne peuvent rien contre l'étalement
urbain
le prix des terres agricoles est trop
élevé les villes et les promoteurs n'en
ont que pour le développement
beaucoup de gens incluant moi-même
pensent qu'on devrait limiter au minimum
le développement sur les terres
agricoles que la barre devrait être très
haute pour y arriver mais ça ne se passe
pas comme ça en Ontario peut-être non
bien qu'il possède parmi les meilleurs
terres cultivables au pays l'Ontario a
choisi de ne pas protéger tout son
territoire agricole
[Musique]
contrairement au Québec et à la
Colombie-Britannique ou des commissions
de protection du territoire agricole
encadre les activités sur l'ensemble des
terres cultivables l'Ontario c'est
plutôt tourné vers une approche de
protection ciblée les ceintures de
verdure
les premières ceinturettes ont été sur
toi en Angleterre surtout sur le côté de
Londres où on a fait réellement une
ceinture pour éviter justement
la disparition des terres agricoles la
disparition des milieux naturels et ça
c'était dans les années 1935 donc son
père quand même de avant-gardiste
la première ceinture de verdure en
Ontario est créée en 1950 autour de la
ville d'Ottawa géré par un organisme
fédéral cette ceinture protège
aujourd'hui plus de 20 000 hectares de
terres agricoles et de conservation
autour de la capitale fédérale
dans la région de Toronto il faudra
attendre l'année 2005 pour voir
l'établissement d'une imposante ceinture
de verdure
de verdure que nous avons aujourd'hui
est le résultat d'une série de décisions
passées et de politiques publiques qui
ont permis de protéger des ondes
spécifiques
la création de cette ceinture de verdure
s'est faite en plusieurs étapes au début
des années 70 on a d'abord protégé
l'escarpement du Niagara une formation
géologique longue de 725 km qui établit
une démarcation dans le paysage du Sud
de l'Ontario
de ses attraits principaux est bien sûr
les chutes du Niagara
mais l'escarpement du Niagara renferme
aussi une forêt de feuillus unique au
pays la forêt Caroline qui n'existe que
dans cette région de l'Ontario
est uniquement ici au sud de l'Ontario
plus d'espèces de plantes en général
nous avons des écosystèmes de prairie de
savane
en 2002 le gouvernement annonce cette
fois la protection du nôtre formation
géologique d'importance la moraine d'eau
Regis
longue de 160 km cette moraine est un
amas de débris rocheux érodé devenu avec
le temps un seul poreux qui permet la
filtration de l'eau
il a été formé par le recul des glaciers
c'est un réservoir d'eau très important
on dit même de la moraine d'OK Regis que
c'est la plus grande réserve d'eau de
pluie du Sud de l'Ontario
elle est aussi très importante pour la
faune car elle crée une immense corridor
de connectivité nécessaire à la
préservation de la biodiversité et au
déplacement des espèces
et puis en 2005 c'est la création
officielle de la ceinture de verdure
avec l'ajout de plus de 300000 hectares
de terres agricoles
nous avons des terres agricoles parmi
les meilleurs au pays et aussi des zones
de culture unique
les régions viticoles et fruits de
sicoles du Niagara et du nord de Toronto
sont ainsi protégés
de l'approvisionnement alimentaire mais
c'est également une source de
développement économique dont les
régions rurales ont besoin
aujourd'hui composé de plus de 800000
hectares de terre la ceinture de verdure
du Sud de l'Ontario s'étend sur 325 km
depuis l'est de Toronto jusqu'à la
péninsule du Niagara elle est la plus
importante au monde
c'est la qualité de l'air c'est la
qualité de l'eau c'est aussi un milieu
où qu'on retrouve beaucoup de des
couteaux riches entre autres donc il y a
beaucoup d'avantages à ce niveau-là
malheureusement oui il y a des avantages
le mélange entre protection du
territoire agricole et protection des
écosystèmes fait parfois sourciller les
biologistes mais c'est surtout la
superficie de la ceinture de verdure qui
soulève des critiques c'est sûr que
ici on donne dans le milieu naturel il
est protégé parce qu'on est dans une
aire de conservation mais comme de
raison on est entouré on est entouré de
terres agricoles on est entouré de
développement résidentiel ou commercial
aussitôt qu'on parle de à l'extérieur de
la ceinture verte c'est sûr que beaucoup
de développement
sans le vouloir l'établissement de la
ceinture de verdure a accéléré la course
à l'urbanisation en dehors de ses
limites
[Musique]
la création de la ceinture de verdure a
été la bougie d'allumage dès qu'on a
établi les limites les promoteurs se
sont dépêchés d'acheter des terrains et
ça accentuer la pression
comme plusieurs le prévoyaient il y
avait un risque de développement
excessif au-delà de la ceinture verte et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est produit
Bernard pop veut cette fois démontrer
comment le développement affecte le
territoire agricole tout près de chez
lui a Berry à 1h30 au nord de Toronto au
nord de la ceinture de vertus
que nous voyons ici c'est ce qu'il reste
d'une énorme ferme laitière qui a été
opérationnelle pendant longtemps c'est
une terre riche de première classe
et maintenant on va y construire un parc
industriel là-bas il y aura un château
d'eau et de l'autre côté de la route un
nouveau quartier résidentiel de 40
hectares
quand j'étais jeune il y avait des
familles ici une communauté on mangeait
ce que la terre nous donnait un arbre
quand je vois toute cette zone pavée
pour des lotissements et des parcs
industriels j'ai l'impression d'être
dans un cimetière
ce que nous voyons ici aurait été
préservé
dans sa bataille contre l'étalement
urbain elle dirige une coalition
d'organismes écologiste et
d'agriculteurs qui demandent à ce que la
ceinture de verdure autour de Toronto
soit agrandi considérablement
[Musique]
verdure vers le sud et le centre de la
province on limiterait ce type de
développement mal pensé et mal conçu
un agrandissement substantiel de la
ceinture de verdure pour protéger
davantage de territoires agricoles né
toutefois pas dans les plantes du
gouvernement de l'Ontario en fait c'est
plutôt le contraire qui risque de se
produire en prévision d'une croissance
de la population le gouvernement se
garde la possibilité de développer des
infrastructures à travers la ceinture de
verdure telle les lignes de transmission
ou bien des autoroutes
et depuis l'élection de dogford ses
projets s'accélèrent oui
trois projets d'autoroute qui traversent
la ceinture de verdure sont sur la table
ce qui soulève un grand débat
[Musique]
ce sera une autoroute comme toutes les
autres
elle sera un jour congestionné polluante
pour les cours d'eau source de gaz à
effet de serre et Bru
[Musique]
et bien mal placé dans toute cette
histoire
une des autoroutes projetées passera
directement sur ses terres
situées en dehors de la ceinture de
verdure mais surtout locataire face à
tout se développements il n'a que ces
mots pour se défendre
[Musique]
nous n'obtiendrons rien nous aurons tout
au plus un bon coup de pied ou derrière
c'est ce que nous aurons et si j'ai
l'air de plaisanter à ce sujet c'est
parce que c'est tellement ridicule que
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de rire
j'aimerais que les promoteurs de ces
grands projets viennent ici
qu'il voit ce que je vois qu'il prenne
cette terre dans leurs mains et qu'il
réalise tout ce qu'elle peut nous donner
[Musique]